"I'm building the fire station," said Hannah.
"I'm building the pizza place," said Andy.
Their school project was almost done.
The friends looked at their town.
It had a police station and a school.
It had an ice cream store, too.
"Now we need some people," said Hannah.
"Mom, can you take us to the store to buy people for our town?" asked Hannah.
"Not now, sweetie, I'm making dinner," said her mom.
Hannah groaned, "We need people!"
Hannah went into her older sister Kate's room.
Kate was playing outside.
Hannah stood on a chair to reach the tiny dolls from around the world.
Then Hannah quickly walked past the kitchen.
"Hannah," said her mom,...
"...you know you can't play with Kate's dolls without asking her first."
"But we need people," cried Hannah.
"You can use my baby dolls," offered Lucy.
Hannah's three-year-old sister, Lucy, held out two baby dolls.
"Those dolls are too big for our town," pouted Hannah.
"But thanks, anyway," she said.
Then Hannah smiled a big smile.
She ran to her room to get her art box.
"Let's make the people!" she shouted.
"Yeah!" agreed Andy.
"I'll make the workers," he said.
"I'll make the shoppers," Hannah said.
The friends colored and cut.
They glued and they taped.
Glitter, yarn, paper and cloth made popsicle sticks become...
...firefighters, teachers, police officers, pizza makers, and ice cream scoopers!
"Neat!" said Lucy.
"Wow!" said Hannah's mom.
"Cool!" said Kate.
"Tomorrow, let's build a zoo and make our own animals," said Andy.
"Great idea!" said Hannah.